[Music]
ben is with us in st
louis ben what's your net worth hi dave
net worth is 1.7 million
cool break that down for me by category
please
620 000 and a 401 k
450 000 in roth iras
230 000 in taxable account
50 000 and a 529 and the balance is our
home which i'm happy to say is debt free
all right and what's it worth about 350.
350. good
very good very cool how much of this did
you inherit
zero and how old are you i'm 39 my
wife's 36.
wow you did it quick too so your lowest
year of household income and your best
year of household income
lowest was about 50 000 when we first
got married uh
last year was our best 185. cool cool
what do y'all do for a living
i'm a supply chain manager and she's a
teacher
all right very good and did you all ever
work with an investment professional
yes we self-manage but we do have a
professional assign that helps coach us
gotcha and do both of you have your
degrees
we do i have an engineering degree and
she has an education degree
gotcha do you remember the gpas
yeah she beat me i had a 3.1 my wife had
a 3.5 all right
and do you all do any giving as a family
yeah we do we we support local causes in
our community
we give regularly to our church and i
like to also
give time when i was on the habitat for
humanity board where i'm at
very cool that is fantastic now you guys
have done this early 39 and 36
but i want you to tell me ben what's one
of the financial mistakes you made along
this journey
you know i think early on i was a little
too conservative
i was going with some bonds and if i had
to do over again
i would have gone right to stocks from
the beginning that proved to be very
useful later on when i figured that out
okay
and uh you know probably going with the
roth options too i was a little slow to
take advantage of some of the roth
401k options that came out so i think
the younger generation that's
absolute go after that very cool very
good what advice do you have to a 25
year old listening to us
i'd say probably three things you know
make decisions that keep you out of debt
you know we went to school that we could
afford it was a state school but
it didn't affect us long term uh
prioritize your savings over consumption
let everybody else buy all the stuff not
you and then you know take advantage
like i said with the roth accounts and
stick with the stocks very cool
excellent job man
39 years old ding ding well done
telling you way to go hero it's an
everyday
millionaire theme hour we're talking to
real millionaires
they're inspiring people they really did
it
it's not a game this is what it really
is there's so much
trash out there in the on the internet
and in people's minds about where wealth
comes from
and we're proving where it really comes
from
this is the dave ramsey show